how's it going res many welcome back to
another episode of surgeon simulator
we're gonna do something that I'm not
sure if I want to do the last episode we
did the eye transplant and today we're
gonna do the teeth transplant I always
wanted to be a dentist this is kind of a
dream coming trip for me so let's start
off by cutting auger this is disgusting
why am ia dent I don't want to be a
dentist okay let's just cut you open
I mean your head open I mean your
whatever Oh God
the sister goes through his body how do
I get thick damn oh it works okay there
we go
I like its moustache okay
we're gonna have to pull your teeth out
Bob how do we do it I guess we just
break and it one and A two and A three
I'm pretty sure this is not real dad
just do it
Oh God you might want to spit somewhere
oh god he's losing a lot of blood
why did he die that's bulls okay let's
try be a little better at this well I
guess we just hook them out don't we
what the heart what is oh god what is
that I'm sorry Bob oh now he's nose all
right well I guess we started I've get
stopped going to space man what are you
doing let's stop freaking attacking
dildo man what is it don't stop doing it
I got damn it oh it's a [ __ ] okay it's
fine
this is started then why why do you have
to go away there we go
all right now it's I I Bob you might
feel a little potion that's your eyes I
guess we just grind his throat
well God what the [ __ ] is happening oh
[ __ ] he's losing a lot of blood there we
go alright we stop the blood loss I'm
gonna be fine Bob
so is this for teeth yeah I think this
is for the teeth it's there we go Bob
don't eat it Bob you're not supposed to
eat the instrument oh maybe this is like
a nose trimmer or something Bob don't
fight it
Bob what are you doing what if it's Bob
don't cheat on me you're with dog man
okay I don't think that's it I don't
think that's it all my instruments man
stop hammer time Jess this is really
good oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] he lost his hound
right and charge charge charge charge
okay I got it you got a lip up clear oh
god damn it I tried so hard what happens
when you make a love to hammers man keep
telling him goddamn it I Bob hold this
for me thank you
how do we get the damn teeth yeah don't
worry this I'm a professional and you're
in safe hands now if watch out for the
moustache though obesity or moustache
sorry
my aim is a little off I think we did it
we got all the teeth except the one that
we wanted that's okay just just a little
bit more time here
there we go it's off let's get the other
ones while we're at it
there you go Bob you're gonna look like
a homeless person
you look like a bunny Bob it'sit's great
trust me all right so now he needs grow
at choppas you need some chocolate I got
these from some from some orphans
outside I'm not sure if they will fetch
but okay they did apparently all right
well let's put some grinders in then Oh
anyway oh that's not good at all is it
dave is so [ __ ] up bad Oh God don't
cut his face man I don't understand dad
what all right it seems our drill went
to space so we're gonna have to do this
the old-fashioned way
Oh goddamnit I tried so hard on that one
what if we just do it without the thing
can we still do it I gotta stop taking
my hammer Bob hey give it back give it
back give my goddamn hammer back I swear
to god there we go
don't fight me oh god damn it he lost
his heart again son of a [ __ ]
Claire it worked oh my god you're alive
all right let's stop bleeding
god damn it oh no I lost it Oh goddamn
it all right Oh we'll be fine
oh nice oh that's great
that is great oh my god seriously what
the [ __ ]
oh god Bob what that fine no Bob don't
eat yourself what my stop eating your
sound like keep telling you
oh god I'm nightmares don't trim your
mustache right now by we're busy okay
seriously [ __ ] seriously over this
[ __ ] game oh my god okay really I
like I'm trying my heart out here all
right I think we got all the bad to
solid actually I'm not sure though let's
just try all right that's one [ __ ] I
forgot he's hard right I'm like the
tooth fairy
except you get teeth in your mouth no
there's a little bit of defective two
left all right
just don't [ __ ] die okay Bob
yes oh my god so good I mean if you want
me to be your dentist actually let me
rephrase that if you don't want me to be
your dentist leave it like up with this
video I hope you really enjoy watching I
had a lot of fun this is awesome but
first I want to try one more thing how
are you Bob I'm just back because we're
gonna try something new so how did I get
the eyes out last part oh yeah oh god I
don't want to do that [ __ ] again this is
practically my face when I saw boobs the
first time my reaction to everything in
life man you look so good Bob trust me
there we go and now dance
oh man this is turning me on too much
I'm sorry I can't so the next stop is
the corridor mode what is that oh that's
awesome
alright we're gonna do that in the next
one hope you boys enjoy watching I'll
see you I'll see you bros
love you